PROSECUTORS SHOULDN'T HAVE MUCH
DIFFICULTY MAKING THEIR CASE
AGAINST HIM IN THESE VIDEOS
DON'T PROVIDE ANY MORE
INFORMATION OR ANSWERS.
BUT THEY DO RAISE QUESTIONS, SO
WHY RELEASE THEM?
LET'S GET SOME ANSWERS FROM
RETIRED L.A.P.D. DETECTIVE MARK
FURMAN AND THIS MAN WHOSE
18-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTER WAS KILLED.
ANDREW, YOU ARE ON THE RADIO
TODAY AND IT WAS SO MOVING.
WE'VE DONE SO MUCH ALREADY TO
BRING SANITY TO THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT SCHOOL SAFETY
AND SO FORTH, AND OUR VIEWERS --
OUR HEART GOES OUT TO YOU,
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US
TONIGHT.
YOU HAD SOME VERY POIGNANT AND
POINTED WORDS, ANDREW, ABOUT
THESE VIDEOS BEING RELEASED.
READING THOSE TRANSCRIPTS MADE
ME SICK TO MY STOMACH.
SO I'M GLAD THAT I DIDN'T REALLY
LOOK AT THE VIDEOS.
HE KNEW HE WAS GOING TO BE
GLORIFIED IN THE NEWS.
AND USING THE NAME AND PICTURES
THROUGHOUT THE MEDIA IN THE
COUNTRY.
I THINK WE COULD USE A LOT AT
THIS AND NOT REALLY SHOW THEIR
NAMES OR THEIR FACES IN THE
MEDIA.
I THINK IT WOULD MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
>> Laura: THAT'S WHAT YOU
WANT, AND YOU ARE RIGHT, HE
REFERENCED THAT.
MARK FUHRMAN, PREMEDITATED
MURDER IN FLORIDA.
THIS KIND OF EXPLODES THAT.
THERE IS NO WAY, I THINK THEY
COULDN'T CHARGE HIM NOW WITH
PREMEDITATED MURDER AND THAT
COULD MEAN THE POSSIBILITY OF
THE DEATH PENALTY.
TELL US WHY.
>> THE RELEASE OF THE VIDEOS HAS
NO EVIDENTIARY OR INFORMATIONAL
VALUE WHATSOEVER.
HE HAS CONFESSED AND HE WANTS A
LIFE SENTENCE IN EXCHANGE FOR NO
DEATH PENALTY.
THE MEDIA AT LARGE A REQUEST UP
FAITH BECAUSE OF FLORIDA LAW OF
DISCOVERY, ONCE DISCOVERY IS
MADE THEY CAN ASK PRETTY MUCH
ANYTHING THAT THE DEFENSE
ATTORNEY AND THE PROSECUTOR HAS.
THEY OBVIOUSLY SHOWED NO
RESPONSIBILITY BY RELEASING
THIS, THIS INFORMATION NOW IN
FRONT OF EVERY JUROR IN THE
COUNTRY, NOT JUST FLORIDA, IS
SEEING SOMETHING THAT MAKES THE
DEATH PENALTY CASE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THE PROSECUTORS,
BECAUSE NOW, WHEN YOU GO INTO
THAT COURTROOM, THE JURORS HAVE
ALL SEEN THIS.
NOT ONLY DOES HE SHOW
PREMEDITATION BUT HE KIND OF
ARGUES AGAINST A MENTAL DEFECT.
HE SEEMS COMPLETELY IN CONTROL
OF HIS PLANNING, COMPLETELY IN
CONTROL OF THE MANNING, AND THIS
IS HIS MANIFESTO.
>> THIS GUY IS LIKE, HE IS
INSANE, HE DOESN'T HAVE CONTROL
OF HIS FACULTIES.
HE KNEW WHAT HE WAS DOING.
>> WHAT'S WORSE IS THE VIDEOS.
MY DAUGHTER HAPPEN TO GET
MURDERED IN THE HALLWAY AND SO
THAT WILL BE THE NEXT VIDEOS
THAT THE MEDIA WILL BE LOOKING
AT.
SHE WAS ON THE THIRD FLOOR, SHE
WAS SHOT NINE TIMES AND THAT'S
ON THE CAMERA, ALSO.
THEY WILL BE LOOKING FOR THOSE
VIDEOS, NEXT.
THAT WILL BE HEART WRENCHING.
>> Laura: WHAT THEY ARE TRYING
TO DO IS KEEP THE SCHOOL
SHOOTING VIDEO GAME GOING FOR
THE LONGEST TIME.
THANK GOODNESS THAT'S BEEN SHUT
DOWN.
ANDREW HAS BEEN LOBBYING AGAINST
THAT.
MARK, I KNOW YOU HAVE STRONG
FEELINGS ABOUT THAT AS WELL.
PARENTS ARE WORRIED ABOUT
THEY ARE NOT FOCUSED ON WHAT
ANDREW IS FOCUSED ON, HOW TO
MAKE THE SCHOOLS SAFE.
METAL DETECTORS OR WHATEVER THEY
HAVE TO DO TO MAKE THESE SCHOOLS
SAFE.
THEY ARE PRACTICAL THINGS THAT
TEXAS IS DOING AND OTHER PLACES,
THANK GOODNESS.
MARK, FINAL WORDS?
>> WE HAVE LEGISLATION ON THE
WEBSITE THAT PEOPLE COULD LOOK
AT, BECAUSE NOW IS THE TIME FOR
THESE GOVERNORS TO ACT.
THEY NEED TO LOOK AT WHAT
FLORIDA DID, WHAT GOVERNOR SCOTT
HELP TO GET PAST, AND WHAT WE
ARE DOING IN FLORIDA WITH SENATE
BILL 7026.
THEY SHOULD BE PROACTIVE.
WHY SHOULD THEY BE WAITING FOR
ANOTHER SHOOTING, BECAUSE THERE
IS SOME OTHER SOCIOPATH OUT
THERE PLANNING ANOTHER SHOOTING?
THEY SHOULD BE PROACTIVE.
>> Laura: MARK?
>> I THINK WE SHOULD JUST LEAVE
THIS WITH WHAT MR. POLLOCK SAID,
IT IS OUTRAGEOUS AND ANGER AND
SELF-RIGHTEOUS PURPOSE TO STOP
THE SCHOOL SHOOTINGS AND IT